hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel you
know in this video I'll be talking about
something that's uh sort of unique to
the orderflow you know sort of when the
order flow doesn't make sense I think it
makes perfect sense sometimes and you
know before I jump into what I'll be
discussing you know be sure to subscribe
to the channel and if you haven't
already uh be sure to hit the
notification button so whenever I post a
new video you'll get notified of the new
video being posted you know 2025 just
started and I'm trying to make it you
know sort of my New Year's resolu ution
and S to get back in the swing and uh
post more content like this for you guys
so you could just better understand the
order flow all right so what I want to
talk about is you know sort of
when what you don't expect to happen in
the orderflow is actually happening in
the order flow um really helps you
understand what's going on in the market
if that makes sense so think of it this
way um today in the gold was a perfect
example I I'm trying to think of what I
should even title this video I'm
thinking of it understanding negative
Delta at the high of the day you know
you're at your high of the day what do
you expect you expect positive Delta
what is Delta Delta is a net difference
between the aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers taking place in the
market and when we look at Delta we tend
to look at it on a Barby bar
basis and think about it so if you have
a market moving up right you have net
aggressive buying right that's what's
causing the market to go up is the
aggressive Traders lifting the offer
lifting the next offer lifting the next
offer and it Market keeps going higher
but what if the market is going higher
on negative Delta meaning the overall
Delta that's appearing in the market is
negative and today you know gold we had
this nice $20 selloff um that happened
you know really pretty quick we made
this high around 11 and we sold off to
about uh 1130 1140 we sold off 20 bucks
in the gold pretty quick we recovered
some and we closed um you know somewhere
up towards the high but
was there anything here in the order
flow that was going to give you an idea
that hey you know what we could be due
for a
selloff and there was so let's take a
look at the uh order flow here so just
going back to you know because we' had
been making new highs since about 7 in
the morning okay and we did get that
pullback at 7:30 but then you know from
7 basically from around 7:00 in the
morning we went from basically 2670
which is right here all the way up to uh
you know 87 as a 17-point move and then
we basically covered it all back in 40
minutes later um around lunchtime so
let's just go back to around
7:00 you know when sort of the New York
session opens up more or less you know
the New York Traders start coming into
their desks and just get the crosshairs
here so what's going on well we're up
here near the high we you know 701 702
we made that new high and look at the
delta Delta it's small it's- 86 this is
I'm looking at cumulative Delta not on
the bar by bar Delta minus 86 is Tiny
okay for cumulative Delta imagine coming
into the trading day 700 a.m. Chicago
time and we're up near the high but the
Delta cumi Delta isn't strong in One
Direction it's not very strong positive
it's not very strong negative it's just
sort of kind of uh neutral in a sense
right is just 86 which is Tiny cuz you
can see like some of these bars here the
bar right before that's got
129 in the Delta you know you get 50 34
34 so it could go either way positive or
negative but then we start taking out
these highs so again you know if this
was plus 86 I'd look at it the same way
I'm be asking myself why is the Delta so
small we're up here near the highs I
would expect it to be stronger a strong
positive Delta instead of Justus 86 you
know if it was positive 86 I'd be saying
why isn't like plus a th000 okay and
then we start making new highs Delta
it's actually growing more
negative first time we took off the high
was- 86 a little bit later it's - 111
you know still hanging around Theus 100s
in here we start making these new highs
okay and you can see just you do get
some bursts of positive Delta 34 22 42
but just seems outweighed by the
negative Deltas that are coming in you
know- 94 minus 27 it's pretty consistent
- 20 is in here right and you see the
Delta's gone from - 86 to this new high
up here at-
278 okay then you know 7:30 came out you
know we had some fed speak and stuff
today um Market did sell off got some
selling okay so got a big chunk of
negative Delta minus 240 but now we're
at minus a th000 in the Delta but we've
come off from our high okay that's good
that's what you're looking to see as the
market is selling off then we start
recovering going
sideways there is some positive Deltas
coming in but look how small they are 37
4 15 27
1 bam minus 100 in the Delta - 107 then
it's consistently negative 15 17 30 36
couple more small positive Delta is
2723 strong negative Delta minus 73
okay and you just see it's just sort of
humming along the Deltas you know do get
a decent positive Delta here 85 you get
up to the new high get a positive 149
but still by the time you make this new
high the Delta is still- 846 so it's
still negative okay going up you do get
this one burst of positive
Delta 255 positive but then what comes
right back withus
236 so it just sort of of negates itself
right there right you had that big
positive buying and it's followed by big
negative selling okay make a new high
make a new high strong negative Delta
minus 120 and know how do I determine
the strong W I'm just looking at what
the Deltas are you know sort of before
that you know is 120 big yeah if it was
20 no but 120 you know anything over 100
you got here here here here that's it
everything else is you know less than 50
more or less okay
so negative Delta still-
894 all negative Delta in here except
for one bar with 82 one bar with 41 and
everything else is just negative it's
all negative Delta it's all selling
right it's all aggressive
selling as this Market is going higher
now it's not overwhelmingly negative
aggressive selling right CU it's not
really pushing the market down and
imagine that you got aggressive selling
coming in we're making new highs just
off our
highs strong sellers okay that should
have you thinking okay hey you know what
we're making new highs and we got strong
sellers coming in Market's not really
going
down something's got to give either
these aggressive sellers are going to
dry
up or
this these traders that are supporting
this Market on this move
up they're going to be loaded up with
this is gold right they're going to be
loaded up with all the gold that they
they want in their portfol folio and
once they stop buying and I still have
this aggressive selling pressure I'm
going to be looking for the market to
drop okay so it's just you know right
now it's just sort of this tug of war
back and forth you know there's there's
aggressive um selling taking place
that's being absorbed by strong passive
bids coming into the market right and
what do I mean by strong passive bids
well the 83 here 37 you know these are
buyers that are coming into the market
we just traded there right so these are
fresh bids and the aggressive the the
big seller is looking
to distribute his position right and
then we start making these new highs
making these new highs look at the
volumes on these
things 500 700 900 and the Delta is just
69 90 90 it's positive why isn't it like
290 or
190 269 it's just 69 at one point this
Delta was positive 267
then the aggressive selling came in it's
actually moved it down from positive 267
to just
69 okay make these new highs look at
this once we get up to these highs you
know 17 14 22 in the
Delta these Deltas are not positive
after that 29 -2 50 -3 42 now again you
know min-2 -3 is nothing because you
know it could go either way positive or
negative I I treat those as kind of
neutral but still you're making this
High you made a new high you got Delta
of minus three really that's not good if
you're looking for this market to
continue up okay - 42 -71 - 103 -
158 since you made this high it's just
been all negative Delta Delta's grown
from- 1200 to
-600 okay then it sort of pulls back up
a little bit you get a little burst of
buying here in this bar with 113
positive Delta sort of going sideways
suppos you know again it's just all
negative Delta look at this now you're
at minus 2,000 in the Delta okay it's
just sort of hanging around here up here
near the high something's got to give
okay you just sort of humming along
humming along get back up towards the
high again is there any overwhelmingly
positive Deltas in here not really
there's 61 there's 96 here's
34 right but it's this anytime you get a
little burst of positive Delta you
followed with negative Delta right just
sort of coming along in here something's
got to it's like a I don't say like a
rubber band you know when you wrap it
around your
finger but every time you know again you
get some little positive Delta 32 it
comes in with minus 30 right so anytime
there's a bit of positive flow coming in
it it's met with negative flow and then
look at this okay you're coming in here
minus 71 - 55 - 35 okay but still just
sort of hanging around the highs so you
every time you sort of get up near the
highs you get some aggressive selling
coming in okay what's that telling you
say okay again you got to be thinking
sort of bigger picture not you know on a
second byc basis on this stuff this is
more of a a broader picture we're up
here near the high look at the
cumulative Delta is minus 3,000 now okay
finally make a new high make that new
high you got negative Delta minus
41 CU of Delta minus 3000 okay still it
doesn't really want to sell off so
there's still
some supportive buying in the market I
don't want to say aggressive buying I
mean there are people lifting the offers
but you have more people selling into
the bids okay then you get this nice big
positive Delta here 251 beautiful right
and then goes inside negative Delta
negative Delta negative Delta does cut
back on the cumulative Delta from- 3,100
to-
2800 and we're just still hanging around
the high but then we make this new high
11:00 again all that negative Delta
starts coming in here right pulls back
up to that
high within a couple of ticks then it
starts
finally The Levy Breaks right and then
now we're looking at selling off magenta
magenta magenta now I know what you're
thinking that's a very broad General
assessment well there are some tools
that we can use on this
now on the orls trader software right
which I developed to help me see things
in the market that you know might
otherwise go unnoticed by myself is
under here we have
extreme um we got a couple things here
so we
got extreme Delta
volume okay we've got extreme M Delta
color right we got
um where is it the Delta threshold here
Delta volume threshold Delta threshold
right so these are related to these
colors here so 25 and 95 and what that
what that means
is if the the two things okay so if the
bars
Delta closes within 95% of either the
max Delta or the Min Delta it's going to
color it Genta if it's bearish so it
means if it's negative Delta it's
closing within 95% of the Min Delta Min
Delta is how strong Delta was in the bar
now the Delta volume number if that is
magenta it's telling me that the Delta
value minus 80 is closing above 25% or
below if it's negative of the bar's
volume so minus 80 into 218 is minus 36%
so what I'm looking at is you know when
we're making
highs right I want to be seeing actually
what I want to see is cyan colors sort
of this um light blue color for the
Delta which tells me that it's strong
you know this one here right 149 48 but
I'm not seeing that I saw one here this
was at
759 um I think there was one or two more
this is the Delta volume this is also
Delta volume but not the Delta number
this one's it's close here 104 to 117
this is also close 113 to but it's not
within my threshold
okay here's an 83 which is within 95% of
the
85 29% so that's strong
okay but look as we get up here towards
this highs here okay now 17 that's a
small Delta but you see this cyan color
right 28 34 26 44 so I know there
there's some
decent um Delta volume readings coming
in here but look at this right after we
make this new high here at 1059 it's
magenta magenta magenta magenta magenta
magenta strong Delta volume strong
negative Delta volume right look at this
again magenta magenta magenta down in
here look at these readings bearish
bearish Delta volumes bearish bearish
bearish bearish bearish I don't see any
bullish information since this High has
been made here at
1059 it's nothing bullish it's all
bearish it's bearish Delta bearish Delta
volume right and then the rug gets
pulled and the market drops 20 bucks now
again that's on a one minute chart you
could even you know go to a if if you
watch a five minute chart you know
watching Delta on a FIV minute chart you
you're sort of looking for the same
things I mean just right here right
before that big move
down right made that new high look at
this negative Delta negative Delta going
into the highs
strong Delta threshold reading minus 181
a strong Delta volume reading minus 27
right after the high and look at this
negative Delta 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 you know
basically for these are five minute bars
right so 5 10 15 20 25 30 for 30 minutes
consistent selling in the gold at the
highs of the day cumulative Delta runs
from- 2900 to- 3400 so it's increased
by you know 500
contracts right right before the market
drops I mean by the time this bar comes
in it's halfway through probably towards
the end you see that strong Delta number
minus
218 right it's magenta so it's telling
you it's close it's within 95% of Theus
227 that should that should kick you in
the butt saying hey you know what this
Market could probably drop where do you
place your stop right above the
high you know then you get the bar that
you love to see as a Trader where it
just drops you know 10 bucks in one
bar you know even if you go back here
right earlier around 7 when you're sort
of you know got kind of neutral Deltas
you know 145 in the cumulative Delta
minus 87 see the strong Delta at uh 730
but look at this right here 8115 820 830
strong Delta now here's the
thing where do you think it's easiest to
sell in a market that's rising or a
market that's falling you're an
Institutional
Trader easiest place for you to sell is
in a rising market not in a falling
Market in a rising market you can get
good fills in a falling Market you're
going to be chasing that is why in a
market like you see this what I'm
explaining right now you see it a bit
more often than um a lot of the other
markets because of the institutional
participation that takes place in
Gold but if you're an Institutional
Trader and you got a lot of gold to sell
the easiest place for you to sell it is
in a rising market not in a falling
market so when I see this in markets
right especially commodity markets gold
is more of a commodity than anything
else and I understand the player that
are involved right they have big books
positions they're trying to cover so if
I see this Market
rallying and I see strong selling I know
at some point it's going to show some
weakness and it could get a drop like
this of you know a nice I don't say you
know always get a $20 move but you get a
nice strong move
down okay so pay attention to what the
Delta is doing near the high and the
opposite would be true if we're at the
lows and I see a lot of positive Delta
coming in they tell me somebody is
trying to you know Buy in a falling
market right that that's important
information and that's what orderflow
really is it's just information it's up
to you how to use it and use it properly
so again you know if you enjoy my videos
and you want to see more like this hit
the like button subscribe to the channel
you know leave a comment below um hit
the notification buttons you guys new
you you know what to do right you've
been on YouTube long enough so thanks
everyone and I'll catch you guys on the
next video take care